panda
[Music]
au début de l'année, cela se
vendra
entre 270 et 280 je pense,
puis à l'époque nous l'avons comme
trois cent dix trois et demi
mais actuellement
en un mois,
il a quitté ce niveau  à environ six cents
et quelque chose de plus maintenant
et
tant d'industries
utilisent des
camions diesel qui transportent des produits alimentaires du
nord au sud fonctionnent sur
Jésus
[Musique]
financier
donc le
coût de production a
énormément augmenté, ils doivent donc  se réunir
et augmenter également
le prix du pain
de 40.
nous avons peur de
perdre tous nos emplois parce que
ceux qui travaillent dans la brousse
mendient, ils ne fabriquent pas beaucoup de lames similaires
et nous ne vendons pas beaucoup  d'eux
[Musique]
toi